anyway uh so
yeah 15 the study of the 15 and uh
the dose not being a question so like
what was the recruitment based on
what was the uh like how did the study
get conducted yeah so the recruitment
and i really liked this fact it wasn't
people that
you know largely were you know we were
honest about what we were studying but
for most people
it was they were in the category of like
you know not particularly interested in
psychedelics but more of like
they want to quit smoking they've tried
everything but the kitchen sink
yeah and this sounds like the kitchen
sink you know
it's like well it's hopkins so yeah you
know thinking that
sounds like it's safe enough so like
what the hell let's give it a shot like
most of them were in that category which
i really
you know i appreciate because it's more
of a
of a test you know of of
of yeah just like a better model of what
if these are approved as medicines
like what you're going to have the
average participant you know
um uh be like and so the
the therapy involves a good amount of
non psilocybin sessions so preparatory
sessions like eight hours of
of getting to know the person like the
two people who are going to be their
guides or the person in the room with
them during the experience
um uh having these discussions with them
where
you're both kind of rapport building
just kind of discussing their life
getting to know them
um but then also telling them preparing
them about the
the the psilocybin experience so it
could be scary in this sense but
here's how to handle it trust let go be
open um and also
during that preparation time preparing
them to quit smoking using really
standard bread and butter techniques
that
can all fall under the label typically
of the cognitive behavioral therapy
just stuff like before you quit we
assign a target quit date ahead of time
you're not just quitting on the fly um
and that happens to be the target quit
date and our study was the day
where they got the first psilocybin dose
but doing things like keeping a smoking
diary like okay
during the three weeks until you quit
every time you smoke a cigarette just
like jot down what you're doing what
you're feeling what situation that type
of thing
and then having some discussion around
that and then going over the pluses and
minuses in their life that smoking kind
of comes with and being honest about the
this is what it does for me this is why
i like it this is why i don't like it
preparing for like what if you what if
you do slip how to handle it
like don't dwell on guilt because that
leads to more full-on relapse you know
just kind of treat it as a learning
experience that type of thing
then you have the real the session day
where they come in
they they um five minutes of
questionnaires but pretty much they jump
into the
we we touch base with them and they we
we
give them the capsule it's a serious
setting but you know a comfortable one
they're in a room that looks more like a
living room than like a research lab
we measure their blood pressure they
experience but kind of minimal kind of
medical vibe to it
and um they lay down on a couch and it's
it's a purposefully an introspective
experience so they're laying on a couch
during most of the
uh five to six hour experience and
they're wearing eye shades
which is a better connotation as a name
than blindfold but
like you know so they're wearing eye
shades but that's a and and they're
wearing headphones through which music
is played
um mostly classical although we've done
some variation of that i have a paper
that was recently accepted kind of
comparing it to more like
gongs and and harmonic bowls and and
that type of thing kind of like sound
you know kind of um yo you've uh you've
also added this to the science and have
a paper on
the musical accompaniment to the
psychedelic experiences
right and we found basically that the
about the same effect even
by a trend not significant but a little
bit better of an effect both in terms of
um subjective experience and long term
whether it helped people quit smoking
just a little tiny non-significant trend
even favoring
the the the novel playlist with the the
tibetan
singing bowls and and the gongs and
didgeridoo and all of that and um
so anyway just saying okay we can
deviate a little bit from this
like what goes back to the 1950s of this
method of using classical music as part
of this psychedelic therapy but they're
listening to the music and they're not
playing dj in real time
you know it's like you know they're just
be the baby you're not the decision
maker for today
go inward trust let go be open and
pretty much the only interaction
like that we're there for is to deal
with any anxiety that comes up so guide
is kind of a misnomer in a sense
it's we're more of a safety net and so
like tell us if you feel some
butterflies that we can provide
reassurance a hold of
their hand can be very powerful i've had
people tell me that that was like the
thing that really just grounded them
can you break apart trust let go be open
what uh what so
in a sense how would you describe the
experience the uh
intellectual and the emotional approach
that people are supposed to take to
really
let go into the experience
yeah so trust is
trust the context you know trust the
guides trust the overall
in institutional context i see it as
layers of like
safety even though it's everything i
told you about the relative
bodily safety of silica nonetheless
we're still getting blood pressure
throughout the session just in case
we have a physician on hand who can
respond just in case
we're literally across the street from
the emergency department just in case
you know all of that you know
privacy is another thing you've talked
about just trusting that you're
and whatever happens is just between you
and and the people in the study
right and hopefully they've really
gotten that by that point deep into the
study that like they realize
we take that seriously and everything
else you know and so it's really kind of
like a very special role you're playing
as a
as a researcher or guide and and
hopefully they have your your trust
and so you know and trust that they
could be as emotional everything from
laughter to tears like that's going to
be welcomed we're not judging them it's
like
it's a therapeutic relationship where
you know this is a safe container
it's a safe space there's a lot of
baggage to that term but it truly is
it's a safe
space for that for this type of
experience and to to
like uh so trust let's see let go
so that relates to the emotional like
you feel like crying
cry you feel like laughing your ass off
laugh your ass
ass off you know it's like all the
things actually that
sometimes it's more challenging with a
recreate someone has a large
recreational use sometimes it's harder
for them because
people in that context understandably so
it's more about holding your
yeah someone's had a bunch of mushrooms
at a party
maybe they don't want to go into the
back room and start crying about this
these thoughts about the relationship
with their mother and they don't want to
be
the drama queen or king that bring their
friends down because their friends are
having an experience too
and so they want to like compose you
know and also just the appearance
in social settings versus the so like
prioritizing how you appear to others
versus the
prioritizing the depth of the experience
and here within the study you can
prioritize the experience
right and it's all about like you're the
astronaut and we're there's only one
astronaut
yeah we're ground control and i use this
often with
um that's good i have a photo of the
space shuttle on a plaque in my in my
office and i kind of use often use that
as example it's like
we're here for you like we're a team but
we have different roles it's like
you don't have to like compose yourself
like you don't have to like be concerned
about
our safety like we're playing these
roles today and like yeah your job is to
go as deep as possible
or as far out whatever your analogy is
like as possible
and and we're keeping you you safe and
so
yeah and you really the emotional side
is a hard one you know because you
really want people to
like if they go into realms of
subjectively of despair and sorrow
like yeah like cry you know like
it's okay you know and especially if
someone's you know more macho
and you know you want this to be the
place where they
they can let go and and and again
something that they wouldn't or
shouldn't do if someone
were to theoretically use it in a in a
social
setting and like and also these other
things like even that you get in those
social settings of like yeah you don't
have to like worry about your wallet
or being taken advantage or for
essentially for a woman sexually
assaulted by some
creep at a concert or something because
they're you know
they're laying down millions sources
of anxiety that are external uh versus
internal so you just focus on your own
like
right with the beautiful thing that's
going on in your mind and even the cops
at that layer even though it's extremely
unlikely
yeah for most people that cops would
come in and bust them right when
like even at that theoretical like that
one in a billion chance like that might
be a real thing psychologically
in this context we even got that covered
this is we've got dea approval yeah
like you are this is okay by every level
of society yeah
that counts you know that has the
authority so it's
so go deep trusty you know trust the
setting trust yourself
um you know let go and be open
so in the experience and this is all
subjective and by analogy but like
if there's a door open it go into it if
there's a
stair well go down it or stairway go up
it
if there's a monster in the mind's eye
you know
don't run approach it look in the eye
and say
you know let's talk yeah what's up what
are you doing here let's talk turkey you
know
the chat okay right it really is that it
that really is a heart a heart of
this radical courage like courage people
are often struck by that coming out like
this is
heavy lifting this is a hard work people
come out of this exhausted
and it's it can be extremely some people
say it's the most difficult thing
they've done in their life
like choosing to let go on a moment a
micro second by microsecond
basis everything in their inclination is
to
is to say stop sometimes stop this i
don't like this i didn't know it was
going to be like this this is too much
and terence mckenna put it this way it's
like comparing to meditation and other
techniques it's like spending years push
trying to press the accelerator to make
something happen
psychedelics is like you're speeding
down the the mountain in a
fully loaded semi truck and you're
you're charged with not slamming the
brake
it's like you know let it happen
you know so it's very difficult and to
engage always
you know go further into it and take
that radical you know
radical courage you know throughout what
do they say
um in self-report if you can put general
words to it what is their experience
like
what do they say it's like because these
are many people like you said that
haven't probably read much about
psychedelics or they don't have like
with joe rogan
um like language or stories to put on it
so this is very raw self-report of
experiences
is what do they say the experience is
like yeah and some more so than others
because everyone has been exposed at
some level or another
but some of it is pretty superficial as
you as you're saying
um one of the hallmarks of psychedelics
is just their variability
so i'm more stressed it's like not the
mean but the standard deviation
right it's so wide that it's like it
could be
like hellish experiences and and
you know um just absolutely beautiful
and loving experiences
everything in between and and both of
those
like those could be two minutes apart
from each other yeah
and sometimes kind of at the same at the
same time concurrently
so um let's see there's different ways
to
there were some jungian psychologists
back in the 60s um
masters in houston that wrote a really
good book the varieties of psychedelic
experience kind of which is a play on
varieties of religious experience by
william james
uh that they described this a perceptual
level
so most people have that you know when
whether they're
looking at the room without the eye
shades on or inside their their minds
eye with the eye shades on
colors you know um sounds like this
is a much richer um
sensorium you know which can be very
interesting and then
at another level masters in houston
called the
psychodynamic level and i think you can
think about it more broadly than that
you know that's kind of jungian but um
just the personal psychological levels
how i think of it like
this is about your life there's a whole
life review oftentimes people have
thoughts about their childhood
about their relationships their their
spouse or partner
um their children their parents their
family of origin their current family
like
you know that stuff comes up a lot
including every like
like the love just people just like
pouring with tears about like
like how much like it hits them so hard
how much they love people
yeah like in a way that you know for
people that like they love their family
but like it just hits them so hard that
like
how important this is and like the
magnitude of that love and like what
that
means in their life so that's those are
some of the most moving experiences to
be present for is where people like it
hits home like what really matters in
their life
and and and then you have this sort of
what masters in houston called the
archetypal realm
which again is sort of viewing with the
focus on archetypes
which is interesting but i think of that
more generally is like symbolic level
so just really deep experiences where
you have
you do have experiences that seem
symbolic of you know
very much in like you know what we know
about dreaming and what
most people think about dreaming like
there's this randomness of things but
sometimes it's pretty clear in
retrospect oh
like this came up because this thing has
been on my mind
you know recently so it seems to be
there there seems to be this symbolic
level and then they have this the last
level that they describe as the
mystical integral level which and this
is where there's lots of terms for it
but
transcendental experiences experiences
of unity
mystical type effects we often
measure europeans use a scale that will
refer to oceanic boundlessness
this is all pretty much the same thing
yeah this is like
at some sense the deepest level of the
very sense of self
seems to be dissolved
minimize or expand it such that the
boundaries of the self
go into in here i think some of this is
just semantics but whether the self is
expanding such that there's no boundary
between the self and the rest of the
universe or whether there's no sense of
self again might be just semantics but
this radical shift
or sense of loss of a sense of self or
self boundaries
and that's like the most typically when
people have that experience they'll
often report that as being the most
remarkable
thing and this is what you don't
typically get with mdma
these deepest levels of the the nature
of reality itself the subjectivity and
objectivity just
like the the the seer
and the scene become one and and it's a
process
and yeah and they're able to bring that
experience back uh and be able to
describe it
yeah but but one of the to a degree but
one of the hallmarks going back to
william james of describing a mystical
experience is the inf ability
and so even though it's ineffable you
know people try as far as they can to
describe it but when you get the real
deal they'll say and even say that they
say a lot of helpful things to help you
describe the landscape they'll say no
matter what i say i'm still not even
coming anywhere close to what this was
like the language is completely failing
and i like to joke that even though it's
it's ineffable and we're researchers so
we try to eff it up
by asking them to describe the
experience
i love it yeah
you